Ciroc 1 2 1 1 1 1 1 2 3 Ciroc Ciroc rot
you've been everywhere if you met Puff
Daddy
I do pop off daddy P Diddy yes I've met
all of them he also he has a vodka Syrah
he does I heard about it do you think
that if we gave you two vodkas you could
tell which one is Syrah sure because I'm
a vodka connoisseur I am a good judge of
vodka
oh I'll be able to you can tell the
difference you down and do a shot
absolutely I usually hit the table than
being cheers and then you have to like
put it on the ground
old school would be hollering swaller
how much in the room there was this
straight yeah I nailed it right what we
think oh hell we need to taste you at
home first
what was that that is that one not good
I'm just gonna taste the other one first
do you think that this tastes like what
Puff Daddy might taste like do you mean
what you're saying
that's definitely nicer right you know
it you just you don't need to taste the
other one I'll take the other one
Julie's trying to get me turned up I
think I'm getting myself turnt up and no
one else I've been doing a bunch of
these I'm starting to get a little loopy
well that's good that's you are so drunk
right now this is hilarious we do it
this is up you know what I'm proud of
you salute okay Waller yeah here we go
here blue oh that's got to be puff
daddy's yeah how come I think it has
more percentage of alcohol tastes sweet
smooth earthy Irby it has like a hint of
sweetness gotta like pop daddy all right
so between the two which one is more
daddy this one you are correct
oh how you like them apples
oh it's vodka not apples well you know
you are correct yeah I do this do you
think he would make anything he touches
tastes better
I do believe so I believe he has a Midas
touch all right
Puff Daddy man call your daddy yeah yeah
she told me daddy okay son uh yeah I
know that you know the difference
between your back and another vodka so
I'm just going to ask you can we take a
shot together will eww take a shot
together when I count to three we say
Ciroc Ciroc Ciroc let's get some
say so smooth I don't know what this is
what it was this is some more things to
get you to have a good time and loosen
up in Vegas this is beautiful
daddy thank you so much let's go to you
son to your father yes cheers Cheers
that is good so and I want to thank you
guys for being such an inspiration to
revolt
am i information to you yes we cut
because at what we look for in our town
is authenticity and I believe you are
who you are a son this is the greatest
moment in my life
oh and can I um never mind